all the good things are happening in the
stand up is all the things you don't
want to happen to if you're involved in
drug dealing walking around with a ton
of money being too flashy having jewelry
I will say this knowing who you are
strange is walking up to you like are
you that guy if you get too successful
as a drug dealer you get arrested you're
literally treating it like drugs
I'm a barber yeah no one knows me I go
into a club late at night sling some
jokes I'm just like yo chill here
you guys leave it does feel like I'm not
supposed to be enjoying you will be able
to enjoy it I think you should read that
Norm book man these are some really
interesting perspective Old MacDonald's
like bad yeah he's great I feel like a
spoiled little now